nothing like being on two of the biggest
shows right now how does that feel
uh it's crazy it's just one of those
things that just happened you know it
was not planned uh we did not try to do
it um but um
yeah i got that you like the
end of 2020 and jumped onto that and
then was doing another movie and grace
came along and they just happened to be
coming out at the same time so
just one of those lucky things it's a
little crazy it's a lot a lot of work
but it's fun
that's awesome well fans are loving you
on grey's anatomy which must feel good
considering obviously that show has such
a strong fan base what's so cool is that
you appeared on a single episode in 2018
and now you're back why are you so
excited to come back for the show
uh i had a lot of fun with ellen you
know that's just the the honest truth we
had chemistry right right away and
that's kind of rare and you sort of mark
that when you come onto a show or a
movie or you know you work well with
somebody and it was just a one-off back
then in 2018
um and i just come off you know two or
three year run on another show and i
wasn't really ready to jump on to graze
at that point but when it came back
around this time you know we talked a
bit and i just thought it'd be fun so i
jumped on
how would you describe your chemistry of
ellen like why is it what is that spark
between you guys
i don't know i think
i just respect her deeply she's been
doing this a long time on that show and
she runs that set so well and the minute
we started reading words it's not like
this crazy thing it's just she's a
really good actor she's able to be
present in the moment the words are good
and we just connected on that level um
yeah it's not that it's not that crazy
but thing it's um more of a simple thing
when somebody's really ready to play
it's often there
yeah the magic just happens to be there
that's so cool uh when it comes to dr
nick marsh what are we gonna learn about
him he's got some secrets to season i
don't know i think to be totally honest
with you i think they're trying to
figure this out they weren't sure if i
was going to be able to do the show or
um i was going to be able to be in the
first five episodes or not because of
this other movie i was doing overseas so
i think everybody's trying to figure out
where this is going but it's a great
writer's room i'm going to keep talking
to them and they're going to keep
thinking about it and we'll see what
happens in the last 15 episodes but yeah
yeah i have no idea i'm the last one to
know really
well i'm sure you've seen all the fan
reaction they're very excited to have
this character back
have you seen the comparisons to your
character and mcdreamy
yeah
you know
even before all this you know when i
would get stopped on the street when
people say i look like somebody a lot of
people say i look like that guy so
um
mr mcdreamy patrick dempsey so yeah
that's kind of normal i think he's such
you know obviously an icon of that show
so i think any new dude that comes on
the show i was going to get compared to
him especially when he's running for
meredith so um that's fine it's funny
you need your own name
what's that you need your own name now i
know but i don't think that's going to
happen i think
that mcdreamy mcsteamy stuff seems like
so long ago i don't think anybody gets
new names like that on that show anymore
so
i don't think i got one going your
character's special it might happen
we'll see
there's so much speculation about when
graze is going to end and then of course
with your character so much talk about
will you will this character be meredith
happily ever after i know you don't know
anything or whatever tell me right now
but would you love to see these two end
up together
yeah i think that'd be an interesting
way for meredith to ride off into the
sunset but i mean i don't think it's
going to be that simple if that happens
and truthfully i don't know and being
very honest i don't think they know so
um
something will have to complicate
everything it can't be that simple it
can't be just easy it has something
really we have to earn that moment if
that's what happens so
um again i'll i'll be i'll be watching
like you see what happens
that's cool uh so let's talk about you
did you get used to the penn badgley
creepy stare he does it so well um he
does you know he's such a nice guy and
such a great actor and
purposefully tried not to
research the show too much or you know
understand what it is and have the other
two seasons in my brain i just kind of
wanted to jump on and play that part and
come into it fresh
um so
you know some of the voice over stuff he
does is challenging because he actually
while you're acting they actually read
it someone off camera reads it so we can
get the timing down so you'd be in sort
of a dynamic scene and then all of a
sudden somebody's doing the voiceover
over here and you'd have to wait and
just stare at each other a little bit so
that's fun um that took a minute to get
used to but yeah he's still great he ran
that show really well it's a tough job
and he was calm and great and lovely the
whole time yeah um so what can you tell
us about this character because what's
really cool is there's a bit of mystery
about your character we don't
yeah that was kind of the fun part to me
because
all i knew was where he started and
where he ended up and he was this sort
of
really put together guy who has
everything going seemingly very
controlling
yeah seemingly and then events transpire
and he falls apart and that that's
that's all i knew but i knew that was
going to be kind of a fun journey to see
this guy who's got everything together
completely fall apart and i knew i could
really go there with the character so
yeah so when did you shoot the show
again you uh 2 20 2020 um at the end of
that into 2021 um yeah and then
went to do this movie came back and then
started shooting grace
oh cool okay well then i don't know if
this question will relate i don't know
like uh the perfect timing but obviously
ken badly plays a new dad in this series
he's a new dad in real life we know that
your partner announced you guys were
expecting back in may did he give you
any data likes
no
no we had some really tense
scenes so you know
i was just there trying to do a job we
talked a bit but not too much about that
stuff i knew the last three four weeks
of filming i think that we were
expecting so i wasn't telling anybody or
anything like that so no i was just i
was honestly the only thing i i noticed
was how
i knew you had a newborn and but he
looked great and didn't seem tired so i
was wondering how he was pulling that
off which is what i'm gonna have to
figure out now
so i was seeing what was going on there
amazing do you think you'll be better at
diaper duty or the sleepless nights
i don't think i'll be good at either of
those
um the diaper duty we've done some
diaper lessons and i've failed terribly
at both lessons and so my girlfriend
looks at me like i'm pathetic but i'm
gonna get better at it practice makes
perfect so i'll get better at that as we
go i love that so much uh will your
little one know about her canadian roots
yeah i mean yeah it's been a strange
time as it has been for everybody i
haven't been back to canada in a while
now this is the longest stretch that i
have been back you know since i moved
from toronto down to los angeles so
i'm really my mom's going to come down
soon which is you know i haven't seen
her for two years so that's going to be
great but you know i miss my friends
there big time so i'm hoping to get back
soon and bring the little lady
oh that's so exciting for you
yeah we got a name that's kind of the
only thing we've been keeping secret but
we got a name for sure
that's awesome so obviously i'm a huge
fan of felicity like so many other
people out there um didn't you think
that when you first shot that show you'd
still be talking about it 20 years later
um
i don't know if i thought about it like
that i did
feel and i didn't know anything i was a
dumb kid when i got that show but i did
kind of feel like it was special
um when i first heard about the show
that they wanted me to audition for it
i said no to the audition i didn't want
to do that kind of a show and then
somebody sent me the script and when i
read the script it was clear
that it uh was a special writing and a
special premise um and when we shot it
with carrie the lead and jj matt matt
reeves you know it just had that feel of
a special show but i you know yeah who
knows i didn't know i'd be talking about
in 20 years but it you know i didn't
know enough back then to see okay this
could be something
yeah you know it's one thing to see you
know what the cast has gone on to do but
then to see what jj abrams has done with
his career that was something pretty
cool for you to watch that well yeah
matt reeves too i mean you know
the new batman coming out with robert
pattinson and you know he's he's doing
incredible but yeah jj i mean
you know again i i i didn't know what i
didn't know back then you know kind of
took it for granted just those two guys
working on their first tv show together
and
one really complimented the other you
know jj is hilarious and he's great with
story and all this and that's you know
very serious and he would do 15 takes of
one shot and you know all of that which
doesn't happen you know on television
anymore really so and we shot on film so
yeah i was very very very lucky to be
part of that yeah just curious because i
loved it so much what'd you think of the
trailer for the batman
uh i i try not to you know they do a
teaser then they do trailer one then
they do
um so i have a rule about watching third
trailers because the third trailer
they're doing the two and a half minute
three minute trailer and it kind of does
the three acts and i hate when they give
away too much but what i have seen i
thought was really dynamic so um yeah
and i think it looks different i think
it looks really interesting
that's cool now you seem to be very busy
you are going to be in a film directed
by lena dunham and in a film directed by
david cronenberg yeah yeah i did the
lena dunham movie while i was shooting
you um they were both in los angeles and
it wasn't a big time commitment but a
really fun part
and she was incredible um i loved
working with her she was great um it was
kind of a crazy part so we'll see how
that goes i play this sort of
extravagant
porn star um so that was interesting
oh yeah that was cool
um we'll see how we'll see it i haven't
seen anything but yeah i have a lot of
fun doing it so i am excited for people
to see that and then the cronenberg
movie
that's a weird great dark movie i'm
really excited about it's kind of the
best role i've had on film in a long
time if ever so
yeah
i just talked to cronenberg the other
day and he's so nice yeah that's the
thing nobody really i had heard that um
but for his movies everybody thinks he's
going to be this serious dark edgy moody
guy
and he's really not he's a really kind
sweet hilarious man it just has
interesting taste in story and film so
yeah
that was gonna be a good one that one's
going to be exciting cool scott so nice
getting to talk to you um
obviously been a fan since felicity but
then to see like everything that you've
done especially this killer year you're
having it's really exciting yeah thank
you so much i appreciate it